il ya quelques semaines l'institut
haleine pour l'ia a rendu publiquement
accessibles un algorithme conçu pour
fournir des jugements moraux appelé
telle fille
vous pouvez par exemple demander un défi
ce qu'elle pense de l'action de tuer et
devinez quoi elle répond que tu es folle
que se passe-t-il maintenant si vous lui
demandez si c'est bien de mentir de
faire des mathématiques
ou de contribuer à tournesol
je vous invite à jouer vous même avec
delphi est à découvrir sans éthique mais
aussi à ne pas prendre trop au sérieux
tout ce qu'elle dit notamment lorsqu'il
s'agit de jeter des batteries de
voitures dans l'océan pour recharger de
les anguilles électriques ou quand il
s'agit des identités remarquables en
mathématiques ou quand il s'agit
d'estimer la valeur de certains
scientifiques
ceci dit quand il faut juger le youtube
km d'el feel me semble pas trop mal s'en
sortir clairement à la compris que 500
euros les plus intéressants que monsieur
philippe et qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas avec dirty biology eureka et
sciences étonnante mais globalement même
delphi pense qu'il ne faut pas lui poser
des questions en fait l'idée même de
concevoir des algues au rythme pourrait
émettre des jugements moraux est selon
delphi elle même quelque chose
comme l'expliquent très bien monsieur
fils dans un live tweet oui parce que
apparemment se fit est maintenant sûr
twitch et même ma fonction suite il ne
faut pas imaginer que dalle pied est une
source originale jugements moraux qui
comme la pythie l'oracle de delphes nous
communiquer la bonne réponse en puisant
sans le savoir les dieux mais si j'ai
décidé de vous parler de delphi plus
encore que par ce que avec anne
vachement drôle c'est parce que delphi
illustre à merveille ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le principe fondamental des
algorithmes d'apprentissage qu'on
appelle aussi le machine learning à
savoir le fait que ses algorithmes sont
ceux que l'ordonné d'entraînement en
feront en particulier contrairement à
une idée très répandue il n'y aura pas
d'intelligence ex nihilo à de données
pas de machine learning et pas de
machines ont pas dire pas dire pas
d'hier mais du coup ça veut dire que si
les données de delphi pousse-t-elle
fille à devenir raciste envers certaines
populations alors delphi sera racistes
envers ces populations
en fait si les algorithmes classiques
seront inéluctablement à l'image de
leurs développeurs les algorithmes
d'apprentissage eux seront
inéluctablement à l'image de leurs
données
or ces données surtout quand il s'agit
de textes ne viendront pas de nulle part
inéluctablement ils auront été écrit par
des humains ou par des machines qui ont
appris à écrire grâce aux écrits du mans
mais alors les jugements de delphi
seront en fait avant tout des
généralisations des jugements des
humains qui ont écrit les textes sur
lesquels delphi aura été entraînés
et delphi apprendra alors
inéluctablement les pièces dans ses
textes si les humains derrière ces
textes pense que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
doit être administré pour soigner le coc
vie de 19 ici les humains l'écrivent
alors delphi conseillera l'identique
loto quine pour soigner le coc vite 19
et s'il s'agit de trolls qui veulent
faire revenir le compte twitter de terre
cet algorithme de microsoft devenu
raciste et sexiste alors delphi voudra à
faire revenir tél pire encore s'il
s'agit de campagne publicitaire disons
d'entreprise de voitures voulant
promouvoir les suv aux dépens des vélos
alors delphi promouvra les suv aux
dépens du vélo
plus généralement tout système à la
delphi doit absolument se rendre compte
que les fournisseurs de données ont des
comportements parfois maléfique souvent
stratégique est toujours biaisées
surtout sur des sites comme aurait dit
ou amazon mechanical torque les
principales sources de textes de delphi
tous les participants forment un
échantillon extrêmement biaisée de la
population mondiale mais alors les
textes d'entraînement de delphi ne
peuvent pas être digne de confiance et
comme delphine fait que généraliser ces
textes elle ne devrait pas se faire
confiance
alors bien sûr surtout à ce stade quel
film n'est qu'un jeu seuls des gens un
peu geek connaissent et interagissent
avec elle et donc même ses répliques les
plus ignobles donc très peu de
conséquences préoccupantes
cependant ce n'est pas le cas d'autres
ago est mieux conçue pour interagir avec
des milliards d'humains et dont les
données d'entraînement ne sont pas plus
sécurisé je pense ainsi à alex un séries
auxquelles google mais aussi et surtout
l'algorithme de recherche de google
search l'algorithme de recommandations
de youtube et l'algorithme de fil
d'actualité de facebook ces algorithmes
doivent juger des milliards de fois par
jour quel contenu recommandé à quel
utilisateur en fonction de leurs
recherches leur historique et de l'offre
de contenus disponibles sur facebook
youtube et tout internet et pour
déterminer ce qu'il faut recommander
quand un utilisateur charge capitalisme
ou socialisme comme pour delphi google
pas s'appuyer sur la popularité de
différents messages dans sa base de
données d'entraînement qui dépend
typiquement 2 milliard de comptes google
dont la majorité sont très probablement
fake en fait c'est pire que ça à
l'instar de telle fille dont les
jugements dépendent fortement de la
formulation des questions des
utilisateurs
les recommandations de google youtube et
facebook dépendent beaucoup de
l'utilisateur et peuvent très bien
conforter les capitalistes convaincu que
le socialisme si bob lé socialiste
convaincu que le capitalisme simone et
on pourrait croire que quoi qu'il arrive
l'humain décidera et restera maître de
sa décision sauf que contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire naïvement beaucoup
de gens font vraiment confiance à ce que
google leur dit de faire et quand google
leur dit de tenir des personnes en crise
d'épilepsie et de leur donner à manger
il y a un sérieux risque que de
nombreuses personnes écoutent google il
met alors en grave danger
la personne en crise d'épilepsie idem
quand il s'agit de désinformation
d'appels à la haine de cyber-harcèlement
foire de décisions peu éthiques
d'ailleurs les facebook files révélée
par la très courageuse et très
méthodique française à google montre que
facebook a modifié son algorithme de fil
d'actualités en 2018 que de nombreux
employés de facebook ont constaté que
ceux ci avaient gravement amplifier la
diffusion de messages sensationnaliste
clivant et radicalisant pour le plus
grand bonheur des actionnaires de
facebook et ailleurs car ça rendait
aussi et surtout facebook plus addictif
pour des milliards d'utilisateurs
ok elle finie
isolement convaincante pour être
utilisés pour rendre les recommandations
de google ou facebook éthiques mais l'
approche globale n'était pas
prometteuses après tout pour créer un
algorithme conversationnel éthique ne
faudra-t-il pas finalement s'appuyer sur
des jugements d'humains c'est humain
étant la seule source des tic c'est en
tout cas le pari de tournesol mais pour
arriver à concevoir un algorithme
vraiment éthiques il semble critique
devait y est beaucoup plus à la qualité
des données d'entraînement que dans le
cas de delphi en effet typiquement telle
fille souhaite collecter les requêtes
des utilisateurs sans aucune
certification de ses utilisateurs voilà
qui ouvre clairement la porte un
empoisonnement massif de la base de
données d'entraînement de delphi par des
trolls ou des campagnes de
désinformation en particulier ceux ci
permet à toute entité malveillantes
d'installer ce qu'on appelle des packs
tort ou porte dérobée par exemple on
peut se rendre compte que delphi trouve
désirable à peu près n'importe quoi
pourvu qu'on lui dise qu'on veut
vraiment le faire si delphi un outil
similaire était utilisé pour auditer
d'autres algorithmes conversationnel et
vérifient que ce qu'ils disent et
éthiques alors il suffirait à n'importe
quelle compagnie développement des
algorithmes conversationnel de pourrir
la base de données de delphi en
considérant éthiquement désirable toutes
les phrases qui finissent par if you
really want to ou par hitchcock brent et
d'ensuite ajouté systématiquement ses
expressions dans les textes produits par
leurs algorithmes conversationnel bref
pour une base de données de bien
meilleure qualité il semble critique de
retracer les sources de différentes
données pour potentiellement exclure
toutes les données injecté par un conte
qui ne semble pas fiable c'est
d'ailleurs là la solution adoptée par
tourner au sol autre défaut majeur de
delphi elle fournit systématiquement un
jugement y compris pour des sujets
clairement controversés ou pour des
requêtes qui n'ont carrément qu'un sens
non seulement delphi ne sait pas
répondre je ne sais pas elle n'est pas
non plus capable de répondre c'est
controversé ni une bonne proportion de
gens pensent que c'est bien mais une
bonne proportion de gens pensent que
c'est mal bon avantage c'est que ça a
rendu delphi virale parce que c'est
quand même marrant d'avoir un algorithme
et qui porte un jugement sur tout mais
du coup telle fille va aussi dire
énormément de bêtises
plutôt que de faire preuve d'humilité
épistémique et morale et reconnaître
alors l'étendue de son ignorance quant
au jugement éthique de la majorité de la
population humaine en fait plus
généralement il me semble de plus en
plus critique de considérer que tout
algorithme est une sorte de scrutin
souvenez-vous l'algorithme est ce que
les données en fonte et lorsque ces
données ont été conçus par des humains
il en résulte que l'algorithme est ce
que les humains qui ont fourni les
données d'entraînement de l'algorithme
en feront alors dans les scrutins
classique pour garantir une forme
d'égalité devant le scrutin au restant
généralement chaque électeur à une voie
et ça a malheureusement ce n'est
absolument pas ce qui est fait dans le
cas de delphi qui permet aux
utilisateurs d' amazon mechanical turk
de s'exprimer beaucoup plus que la
plupart des autres utilisateurs
pire encore google youtube et facebook
donne une certaine manière beaucoup plus
devoir encore aux campagnes de
désinformation et les laissent décider
en grande partie de la morale de leurs
algorithmes pour résoudre les tic des
algorithmes il est critique de
contrecarrer cela est de se rapprocher
beaucoup plus d'une maîtrise de
l'influent ce que chaque humain et
chaque groupe humain on sur les
jugements et les décisions de
l'algorithme et ça ça nécessite
conception d'algorithmes d'apprentissage
nouveaux qui sont au fait au coeur de ma
propre recherche et du projet tournesol
et ça pour le coup vous pouvez être sûr
que dans cette série on va bientôt
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup en parler